I call myself a Tesla fanboy I was
driving a Tesla for a year it's to the
point that I can't drive regular
vehicles anymore if we recall the first
time you got an iPod
it was amazing wasn't it you went from a
cassette player to this amazing little
device on which everything was was was
called solid-state remember solid-state
electronics that there were but this
with this amazing advanced we saw in in
technology that were less what feels
like to drive a Tesla I call it a
spaceship that travels on land no gears
no bumps you step on the accelerator the
car literally flies and it flies so fast
that when my wife is sitting with me she
complains vivec we just had dinner
please I'm gonna throw up if you if you
go like that because it feels like
you're getting into warp speed the car
literally seamlessly picks up torque
like you won't believe and and flies
this is the future of the transportation
industry that that we're going to have
clean vehicles that fly that's the magic
of electric now what's holding back the
this industry is a cost of batteries
knowing Elon Musk he's been a far far
exceed his anticipated 30% savings by
2017 I wouldn't be surprised if by the
end of this decade we're talking about
batteries costing 1/5 as much so much as
they do today if not 1/5 maybe 1/3 which
means that it becomes more economical to
produce electric clean vehicles which
are like spaceships than to deal with
the you know filthy internal combustion
engines they were dealing with right now
these machines that we put that horrible
liquid into the explosive liquid called
petroleum and then you have to load them
up with that black viscous liquid called
oil pollute the environment these cars
as clunky as held those internal
combustion engines it's time for them to
go we need to replace them with electric
engines and this is why I've become such
a Tesla fanboy because it's the first
real you know electric vehicle that is
better than anything else ever made
you